what's happening you bad [ __ ]
the church of what's happening now is in
full effect but before we before we get
started i want to introduce you to our
sponsors number one aren't you sick and
tired of paying too much for raises yes
you are so that's why i'm coming at you
with the best razor out there you ready
dollarshaveclub.com what i'm going to do
is i'm going to get you the first month
the executive razor with a tube of dr
carr shea butter for only five dollars
but do me a favor go to
dollarshaveclub.com right now slash
church that's
dollarshaveclub.com
church number two what are you sitting
there like a mook on a mutt just sitting
on the couch watching all the nba
playoffs listen i got a job for you
ready
lyft the number one ride-sharing company
that believes in treating its people
like people you don't need to be broke
no more to join the best ride sharing
company that believes in treating people
like people go to lyft.com right now
slash joey today and i'll get you a 500
new driver bonus okay limited time only
terms apply again lyft.com
joey
lyft.com slash joey hit it lee
oh [ __ ]
break out the [ __ ] fentanyl
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
mate
[Music]
the church of what's happening now
becky on roller skates
from math
yet
michael jackson
say what the [ __ ] you want to say here
we go
molesting kids whatever the [ __ ] he's
doing
the giraffe
hit it
out i said lee
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here on a wednesday night
we're over here in the voodoo lounge
in the studio of death i'm sorry about
monday night
listen i told you i bled to death i told
you [ __ ] the stories my brain
relived it and i [ __ ] passed out i
went down everything came back like 30
minutes later lee and i went for a ham
and cheese on a bagel
with a [ __ ] coke my body was craving
you know after you pass out like that
you want a soda i work hard
guys i've worked for [ __ ]
it's got to be 30 years on this passing
out situation
like i've been actually working on it
like i dread
those times that i won't handle it
because that's what happens to me
like if somebody's bleeding around me
i'm a 50-50 toss-up are you one of those
blood people you can't you can't yeah no
no no no so that's what made me
passionate so you really passed out like
you legitimately passed out that night
here yeah it was the same feeling i get
when i give blood
and i or i get a needle and like i got a
needle once for
i came back positive for syphilis
when mercy was
when terry was pregnant
they gave us these tests
and terry came back negative
i came back positive for syphilis whoa
so i went back again and they said it
wasn't syphilis oh it was like a false
positive it was like a false positive
so the guy goes listen just to be safe
whatever let's just do four shots
so they give you two shots on each cheek
and they gave me the first shot i didn't
see the needle i didn't hear the needle
i didn't hear it just a prank going into
my ass
i made them take it out
i [ __ ] was sweating
my [ __ ] neck start sweating asleep
when i got up from the chair there was a
bead of sweat going down the chair
it's a it's a fear it's just a [ __ ]
fear that i've had and it used to be
really bad
then i started controlling it
and now i know how to control it but i'm
always 50 50.
huh like my mind knows to shut it off
look oh [ __ ]
just don't look at that way and i don't
look at it and you never know there's
times i cut myself
in the shower shaving or something in a
rush at the same time do you get the
same feeling well sometimes i look at
the blood and i'm fine but sometimes i
look at the blood go out dry myself
right
go
powder put [ __ ] armpit [ __ ] soap
on
[ __ ] put visine in my eyes put my
socks on put my shirt on and i go in the
bathroom i look at the towel and there's
a little bit of blood on it i gotta go
sit down
i gotta go see that so it's a 50-50
[ __ ] toss-up and i had a cat finney
god bless his soul
i love finney but finney got to know me
so much
that he knew when i had those feelings
and becky you cannot call how he knew
huh so whenever you have instincts when
we first moved down this corner here
there was three situations where i
fainted within the first year really
yeah one time i went in the closet and
the clothes was hanging i didn't know
that that clothes
hides a [ __ ] metal rod
she knocked herself out oh my god and i
went into that [ __ ] thing head first
like you know like jack lambert nady
what do you think was holding up the
clothes no no no no no no the clothes
were here this metal pole was right here
oh okay guys there's an extra an extra
allison
and i'm holding on to my head and i'm
[ __ ] bleeding and i'm like i'm going
to be fine i'm going to be fine i'm
going to be fine i'm not going to be
fine
i run for the living room i take my
shirt off and i put the air conditioner
on [ __ ] alaska
and i sit there in front of this air
conditioner
until the [ __ ] air conditioners and
awesome the cat would jump on top of me
and i love this cat with all my heart if
it was anybody else i would punch him
right in the [ __ ] head get the [ __ ]
away from me
but i would look at him and want to
throw him off me
but just the thought of me going to
throw him off him i sit back and go
[ __ ] finney and i go
and also i go oh my god
because
i took my mind off fainting
this cat would jump on me and put his
claws into my thigh oh so you'd think
about that instead of the action and it
would take me right off
another time something happened i was
getting sick i was puking something like
oatmeal like i must have had like a mini
stroke or some [ __ ] something happened i
was puking like this oatmeal i'm
[ __ ] i'm puking
and the same thing i went to the living
room i thought i was gonna faint
i got like food poisoning i'm
sitting in front of the air conditioner
completely naked
sweating and it's freezing and i'm
sweating wow that's a terrible feeling
that's a terrible feeling and all of a
sudden he jumped on me with his claws
and he got me right around the dick
like right around like he put two paws
here and two paws oh my god so you can
see like four little holes
with his little [ __ ] claws and he
just and i wanted to push him again and
again he healed me
wow and then one time i caught my
association yeah [ __ ] crazy smart
little cat yeah i'll faint in the drop
of a [ __ ] dime guys
wow i fainted at the ufc
too much blood yeah from too much butter
a towel oh my god a corner man threw a
towel
and it was filled with blood and i was
at ralphie may the
the smaller ufc venues what's the
smaller one when they used to do the ufc
car like the house but they'd have like
a headliner
it's a younger casino the palms the
palms oh yeah they did use that was a
long time ago right
and then one time i was watching b.j
penn against big joe daddy stevenson
i went to the comedy store i was out
doing comedy i get home my wife's
sleeping it's gotta be two thousand
eight
nine
everybody's sleeping
i sit on the [ __ ] couch
and i'm replaying the ufc you know you
you play you went out and you missed it
at eight o'clock and
it's joe daddy against bj petty kicks
him he hits him i don't know what
happens
joe daddy's bleeding gallons like me on
thursday night he's bleeding gallons out
of his [ __ ] head
and in the couch i fainted
and i woke up two hours later dog
boy [ __ ] drenched in sweat
like i must have lost four pounds of
sweat because your body goes into this
[ __ ]
horrible i've had this disease since
i can remember what about movies and tv
shows like when you know it's fake blood
does that [ __ ] you um a little bit do
you know that i turned on one of my
favorite episodes i like carrie when
they spill all that blood on her no that
doesn't bother me because you know
that's fake uh pulp fiction uh-huh when
they stick the needle in his heart oh
yeah
[Laughter]
the girl i was with put
milk chocolate raisinettes in my mouth
that's what made me come back
she brought me back with raisinets
you just went down right in the theater
man down in the movie theater
a mouth open
drooling from the mouth shaking like i'm
an epileptic oh my god and my friend j
kyle and me and his girl and
the [ __ ] flute i was with what about
when you all kicked weidman in the head
that cut didn't
no if i was if i was there you might
have gone and i would have heard the
knee hitting the head yeah and then saw
the blood you understand oh really yeah
it's different uh
it's different situations
lee could bleed to death
but if i see you bleed i might feel you
know what i'm saying like it's just
really weird mm-hmm yeah he has to care
for them
yeah i'm sitting there i'm sitting there
and i'm thinking about an episode of
sopranos
one particular episode
one particular one
after he gets shot he's at the hospital
and he meets the old man that was the
foot traffic guy over at bell
laboratories
and he kept calling him a rocket ship
guy the rapper got shot and they put him
in a hotel room and then he had like
satellite tv so tony went in there
with the [ __ ] old man and the rapper
and treach from naughty by nature was in
there
he was holding the satellite dish and it
was just a really [ __ ] good episode
but i'm watching tv i'm like you know
man i get home
i set the real cool you know this takes
me an hour because you know i'm half
[ __ ] i gotta press this
touch this he [ __ ] himself gotta log
back
tv show i don't know [ __ ] nothing i
just want to see a soprano i would pay
to watch that just you'd figure out the
tv at like two in the morning so i get
up i get like some cashews in the cup
i got an apple you know i'm ready to
watch the [ __ ] sopranos i'm sitting
there eating this [ __ ] apple
and what do you think happens this
episode opens with him
the stitch it's after he got shot so
he's at the hospital
and he's talking to a black woman and
she's telling them how much long and he
goes well they're going to go to surgery
tomorrow and he's like surgery again
when they showed that
i had to look the other way
i i push away the apples
what about on the fat man show when
they're doing the surgery can you watch
that or no
uh i have my moments i don't like that
the laser the cuts the [ __ ] the whole
thing yeah does it ruin the show for you
does it upset you like when when you get
those moments
are you just like [ __ ] the show it just
really guys it's a 50
50 toss up you know listen i'm sitting
on a [ __ ] plane i'm watching a movie
also i'm going to scratch my face and my
cuticle's sticking out and i'll take a
[ __ ] bite out of my cuticle as you
can see i got skin missing and it'll
bleed like a [ __ ] sieve
and nothing will happen and you're fine
listen to me the other night i bled for
24 hours there was a point where i
looked at the tub and i go
why haven't i fainted yet
and the other night i come in here
high on edibles which is not always good
all anytime that that would really push
cheat that's another situation
if i could be in here you cut yourself
and i'd be fine but if i'm on edibles
and you cut yourself that's a different
trigger yeah like i i still don't get
high and go to jiu jitsu
oh really it would not even be in my
realm that would not that would be
totally disrespectful to me
to alberto i don't know why but uh
seriously it would be too real for me
you said you feel like you suffocate oh
no i die yeah i die now yeah well your
heart gets going an edible no [ __ ]
way he says
someone gets on top of you and it's old
there was a guy today who got on top of
me i couldn't i could not move this kid
two times at a time
not only was he big but he was a
wrestler no but he was big yeah big big
big not muscles big
you know i couldn't get him all right
and he was a wrestler yeah he knew how
to wrestle yeah that wrestling picture
he was doing weird [ __ ] to me and stuff
we had sakayaki [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
it didn't look like japanese and so
what's going on meth therapy it's been a
while
i feel like stained you know what i'm
saying like what it's
i'm over here throwing heather you gotta
catch she
with the cats yep
nothing just uh doing my matt therapy
stuff podcast so for those who don't
know matt therapy covers all realms of
jiu jitsu and wrestling and mma yeah you
guys just covered an event in vegas a
few weeks ago we went out to the to the
us like wrestling championships open
wrestling open championship something
like that
it was i didn't realize what we were
going to and how big of an event it was
it was pretty cool like we saw two
gold medalist wrestlers compete
we saw like the highest level of like
competition wrestling out there
it's a different game isn't it oh
totally
totally because you're in high school
either no
no singlets for me i believe we was a
wrestler
i was on the team i wasn't good at chief
chase jumbo when she
needed a singlet i i might have one of
my mom's house who knows no no no we
have to run them i don't have one i
don't need to single it yet cinco is
better than speedo somebody send leah
singlet wrestling was one of those
things that was very big in my high
school
was it yeah my high school was great new
jersey
my high school was really good and they
had a couple state champions a couple
guys that went to lehigh i think but
uh basketball and wrestling was in the
same season
but afterward i was my friend was a
great wrestler one guy i hung out with
three wrestlers like full time like i
hung out with them did blow with them
ate pills at them went to concerts with
them
and they're a [ __ ] weird bunch but
they were crazy yeah you know the coach
we had was his name was tabaccino
and you would [ __ ] walk into
basketball practice and these guys would
be running stairs
we'd take showers
run back we were walking out and these
[ __ ] would still be running
stairs if you walked into their
wrestling room it was 2 000 [ __ ]
degrees before the hindu came here they
were doing that 2 000 years before that
hindu came here they had those arrested
this is 70 [ __ ] six i'd walk in there
you'd bust out into sweat you have to
make it smell like [ __ ] feet in there
and asses and
uh mildew it smell like [ __ ]
mildewish in there but way before the
the guy showed up with the [ __ ] heat
that he did the indian guy the vikram
way before he showed up with that
[ __ ] thing
they were doing that northberg and
wrestling for [ __ ] 20 hours
with 2000 degrees and
like i hang out with oh no no another
dude didi quintero
so hung out with crowley didi quintero
kurt delorenzo who's dead god rest his
soul and somebody just put a picture up
on him on facebook
and dan reagan who's dead god bless or
so it was his birthday on sunday and
somebody just put a picture up on it
were any of them smaller kids like the
the lower weight classes
was five foot two
oh my god he's shortened he was he was
small he because he showed me the
picture with it he's really buff so i've
always imagined he was heavy but
oh wow because the light guys are always
the craziest or that was always on my
team like the light guys were like the
craziest
wildest guys the light guys yeah like
the 103s oh oh
not all of them but like there was one
in particular who was
he would do the thing where like he
would jump up and like hit himself
before he would do his match
he'd give himself all psychedelics
oh yeah that was after
that was after high school that was that
started his senior year in high school
because by that time this is all he did
wrestlers all they did was [ __ ] lift
weights these [ __ ] savages
so he just went with it
uh i still remember in high school and
he showed up in my house that night with
his shirt on he called me up i'm coming
over with some coke
sit tight
like i had gone back to school and he
was a senior graduating i wasn't going
to graduate i was supposed to go to some
school and i was already thinking about
i'm not going to go to something i'm
just going to play the handout
and he was coming home one night a dog
it's like playing his day was like eight
o'clock
i didn't know what i was gonna do that
night i was kind of in a mental i was in
uh one of those people other people were
saying that it's complicated it's
i was in a complicated relationship at
the time i was hiding before i was
hiding from the blood
so it's complicated i didn't want to get
a g bow and b out and she'd come in and
give me a [ __ ] ear beating so i said
should i stay here and listen he calls
and he goes sit down i'll be there in 10
minutes
a little more than complicated where you
have to hide out from her this is
january
this is january 2 this kid walked in
i was living downstairs with the runnies
and he walks in
and he he brought like an eight pack of
beer and he [ __ ]
you know he takes out the coke he put
some [ __ ] coke down you should make
some more [ __ ] noise becky everybody
shows up a little bottle of water you
gotta show up with rin tin tin you gotta
show up with an oxygen tank that goes to
cuba once a [ __ ] month look at you
you gotta open it up it's got a [ __ ]
uh it's got an alarm system on it it's
got an alarm there's a code so he showed
up at the house becky
and we do a couple lines of cog and we
drink couple beers
but he was dying to tell me something
like what's up dog he wasn't gonna tell
you something promised i can't tell
nobody
like what's that and also he goes hold
on
he rips his shirt off becky
and he gets on the floor right in front
of me he just starts doing push-ups
he does about 40 push-ups
he gets on his back he does a bunch of
crunches and [ __ ] then he gets up he
looks and he goes and he gives me a crab
and he goes i'm doing [ __ ] i'm doing
steroids how do i look i go
you look tremendous and also he broke
down how he started doing them who he
doesn't with
you know this whole thing and it was
very interesting
and for months dog it was
one of the best
times in my life hanging out with him
because he was getting bigger every week
and then by sunday he was yoked because
he would work five days a week so your
big recoup day is saturday by sunday
you're yolked
on sunday you're yolked you juice up and
do and workout monday with like some
squats on wednesday and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] saturday is your day of
soreness but sunday you get up you put a
little [ __ ] suntan lotion on it's
over
[ __ ] are melting at the [ __ ] beach
on sunday right
so
was this at the time when you didn't
know that steroids were bad for you or
did you guys know and they just didn't i
had no idea about about the juice at
this time at all
all the education i had was from him
another dear friend of mine but he was
the one that was cracking me up that
night
and i got a job right after that
bartending in high school i got a job on
wednesdays i wanted that seven in the
morning to bartend
and on monday nights i went there at six
o'clock at night and bartended until
three in high school in high school and
he would come in
i would tell them all drink i'll buy you
one you buy one you know what i'm saying
if you buy three i'll give you four
come on down
don't worry about the tip i'm gonna
steal anyway so don't worry about
nothing here i'm stealing with both
hands here
and after a few drinks and a bump of
coke
i could tell this kid regular anyway
like come here for a second
go do some push-ups show these
[ __ ] what it's all about
do you understand me we could be at a
[ __ ] bar mitzvah and he would take
his shirt off and a pair of underwear
and crab it up and [ __ ] this one this
went on for like a year and a half this
was hilarious was he working with you or
you just brought him with you when you
worked wherever i went t whether there
was free beer we were going to mangle a
package from somewhere
somewhere somehow with mango to bump
what did your bosses say when you showed
up with another dude like hey this is my
friend no no no there was no bosses
there was no bosses there was a girl
like becky that was there from
he was in high school looking at a bar
three to seven and i would come into the
quarter to seven becky would give me the
bank
becky would cash out and i would take
over becky's ship there's no bar he
never met him i'll tell him yeah but i
tell him don't come down until becky
leaves
becky leaves she sits down her boyfriend
comes together they have a drink then
becky leaves
so
they would come down like 8 39
and about by midnight he'd be on fire
between the alcohol the blow that
steroid going through your heart
and like call them over there'd be like
20 guys and they'd call them over their
rigs
go do some [ __ ] jumping jacks some
push-ups take your shirt off show these
[ __ ] we'll hear about and he
would do diamond push-ups
he'd get a vein would come on his head
and he walked around he's walking on the
ball with no shirt on
just like what [ __ ]
nobody would say dicta
wait listen man that dude it's like
seven in the morning they're like what's
happening that was 1982 i met him in
1978
all right we met like playing basketball
he played for st bridget's
and i played for st michaels and
basically it was lincoln school who was
the [ __ ] crazy school if he played
not saint bridges
not a saint augustine right there on
kelly boulevard i can't remember the
name of that [ __ ] place
but they all played there him this kid
fernie who i went to meet mcshea they
all played dead and those leagues you
could be in the sixth seventh or eighth
grade do you follow me and if you were
catholic and you went you gotta go to
church on sunday you could play for the
[ __ ] team it was a scam and you put
up with the church as long as the priest
saw you you were the pill
you got the [ __ ] out of there
so i stayed friends with him
when i when i went to colorado i mean me
and him used to rob car stereos
he had
team member too oh no he was family he
had a car that didn't have heat
in the wintertime in new york city we
used to call it the ice box
every time we go in there you gotta have
gloves on and [ __ ]
but it was a tank it was a tank
and once a week him and i would cut out
of school and we'd go down the tunneling
avenue to the season road bug down there
by by right before chance dragging in
and we'd make a right now
and they put displays up
for car stereos like good car stereos
like blah blah blah
dog and i would walk in regular away
from me in the car
i would walk in
buy like windshield wiper
like two windshield wipers for 299
and with that same bag on the way out
pick up two cars there he was that was
our friday we had a [ __ ] grandma blow
and we could buy a case of beer and we
had like 60 cash between us
that was my mentality that me and one
time we went
and we [ __ ] stole like four car
stereo and maybe six of them as we're
backing out we hit this [ __ ] car
and like there was a guy in the car but
regal hit him so [ __ ] hard
that his car was wiggling for like four
[ __ ] minutes
like we [ __ ] it up we [ __ ] that car
up though
we [ __ ]
that car up and the guy was like no no
no problems and [ __ ] and then
we had that ice box
until the summer and when we were
graduating high school one night we were
going down the shore there was this dude
there was this restaurant called mando's
in paramus new jersey
and the kid's name was merlot
behind his back they called them mort
right
he was cool as [ __ ] i love rob merlot
but we used to call him martin what if
he didn't know what if he finds out
right now no he knows what we used to
call them right to call him
and he had a great sister
and he was this kind of dude on friday
nights his father owned this restaurant
so if he needed dough he'd come up to
you and go listen come meet my father's
restaurant work from 11 at night to
seven in the morning cleaning the place
we do a spotless job you eat whatever
you want just don't touch the shrimp
that's it just promise me you won't
touch the shrimp i promise you first
thing you want the first thing you want
yeah who the [ __ ] is that you're dealing
with i think a live lobster he boiled it
and he's just telling me every week i do
great you and kante come down here the
shrimp disappears i don't understand
this is that all you guys eat let's take
this fish all you got is my [ __ ] trip
we would go there and eat those shrimp
and dip it in those [ __ ] horseradish
jesus christ that would set your [ __ ]
on fire would you actually clean what's
that would you clean
like oh yeah yeah that's the only way we
get a grammar blow between four of us oh
my god so in high school we would be 18.
we'd get a grammar blow put it on the
bar at mando's start snorting
each of us would start cleaning and we
get out of this zip by seven o'clock
join like [ __ ] everybody goes
home happy or
listen to the savages we were because
this was happening you
right there you get out at six six
thirty you're already gacked up you got
a couple beers we'd steal a car a case
from amanda's
it in the car and we drive down the
jersey shore why didn't he just hire a
cleaning crew it seems like it'd be a
lot cheaper than because the beer stinks
you have no [ __ ] it was his son so he
was trying to give his son a little
action give him responsibility and [ __ ]
like that that's why you don't have kids
so we go so what so one friday night
he asked us he goes are you guys going
down the shore and i go yeah
he goes come help me i can't because me
and rhaegar are going into the city
and to get a few eight balls
because we had to kill time that night
we had to wait till two o'clock till my
friend got out of ups
to drive down the shoreline
he worked from 11 to two in high school
in ups and guess what guys
today he runs c caucus ups one of the
biggest [ __ ] districts oh wow yeah
he got paid too he had stock options and
[ __ ] since high school
since 1980 he's been at ups that's how
many years that's 20 that's 37 [ __ ]
years at ups and he's held every job he
started right there with us and on that
friday night the deal was
go to work
we'll go into the city we'll buy the
four or eight balls whatever the [ __ ]
you need and then we'll bring them over
now rule number one with the ice box was
you couldn't turn it off
once you got in the car i had to stay on
the whole night you couldn't turn the
car up till you got to your destination
so the car can't heat itself against my
better will i go rake stop at 178 let's
get a bag of reefer
if we're going to go down the [ __ ] uh
down the shore let's get some reefer too
in those days we used to go to 178th
street maybe 180 and it was a pool hall
and you walked in the pool you walked in
the back and that big guy with a pool
table with 20 different types of weed 20
different types of packages you tell
them what you want you give them the
cash they'd buzz you out
boom nobody said nothing we go up there
the guy gives us papers
i go in the car we roll the number on
the way down i get rhaego tuned up
between 180 and 135 we're [ __ ] tuned
up
the good thing about 135 in those days
is that the cl uh the there were
dominicans colombians at that time that
were downstairs but on the corner it was
a bodega
and becky they had like daily
okay they said it was the heart of
[ __ ] the upper west side
that that's what we did to not make us
look like [ __ ]
we'd walk into the bodega first and buy
a piece of chicken
or or whatever so we weren't just
walking around that neighborhood at the
cospolo what do you what do you three
white dudes doing here all right all
right i'm getting chicken at the [ __ ]
corner you've had you haven't even had
the chicken from the corn office
[ __ ] stealth you know you're throwing
them off you're just not walking out
like a [ __ ] idiot like people do
today i go to the wheat store and
there's people parked in front of the
weeds to go for a [ __ ] ride
didn't you ever buy weed before go for a
[ __ ] hike you're over here
advertising there's a red right there go
for a [ __ ] right around the corner
when he's in there you're supposed to go
buy booze papers condoms for your dirty
ass [ __ ] lighters whatever else you
need razor blades
so yeah we would we would
we went we parked across the street
already we made a u-turn like we were
gonna go right back to the jersey side
to the bridge
i don't know what in those days it was
250 and eight ball i probably had like
eleven hundred dollars on me i was just
gonna give him 1100 and make me give me
whatever the [ __ ] you got it was a
downstairs disc attack i walk downstairs
boom i go downstairs bunch of people
dancing the spanish music the guy's a
horrible dj he's going from like spanish
music to
that's the way uh-huh and it's not
working he's scratching the albums worse
than i do here but wait at 18 you were
spending 1100 it wasn't my money
your money becky's money my money so
we're all getting an eight ball we could
throw a gram on that get four and a half
and sell it a gram for [ __ ] a hundred
dollars and we each keep a half grand
and we can party you know what i'm
saying and
whoever stays up the longest could hang
out with becky late night and [ __ ] and
talk to her and say a couple things you
know what i'm saying
say a couple things sure have her sit
next to him
they had a whole business going
basically so
we're stoned in front of them i'm
getting ready to get the [ __ ] in there
without even knowing
at 11 30 at night
in the heart of harlem
in june on a 90 degree night
darren regal turns the [ __ ] ignition
off
and as he's doing i go did you just
start to [ __ ] call me
and he goes oh [ __ ] i forgot i go oh
[ __ ]
ain't nobody gonna stop and give you a
jumper
you need to jump it every time yeah oh
no
did you just abandon the car no
i can't walk into these [ __ ] savages
downstairs
well this place doubles
as a coat as a chicken then you know
when they have chickens and they fight
in the daytime sure that's what it does
in the daytime and at night they put a
stage down
and people like you know go in there and
dance and they sell blow in the back
it was classic so i can't ask them to
come out this is their spot here yeah
this is their spot
so there's no way i could go in there
and ask them for jumper cables and by
the way i need to jump
so i walk the [ __ ] in there i salute
everybody they all know me hello
oh [ __ ] cuba's you know you get to
talking you had to go into a little dj
booth and the guy had to scale right
there with the dj booth was that's how
wide open
and the door had to be open because he
would stick his hand you see the door on
top here he would niche it out and he
would put blow up there and he would
take out the bag and go what do you want
35 20 i want an 8-ball as a matter of
fact his 1100 off
and he had an assistant who came in and
the assistant would uh
get the [ __ ] aluminum foil
and those days they still gave it to you
in big aluminum foil so here we go what
do you put in there
as an a buyer he would cut out aluminum
foil perfect for an eighth
so that night we filled it up he gave me
like six aluminum foils i had more
aluminum falls than [ __ ] aluminum
foil
i walk out there i [ __ ] go to the
corner now the bodega they got a dog
that's tied up in front of there
you gotta walk past the dog that's tied
up
is it like a nice poodle like a cute
little dog
like a guard dog it's like a german
shepherd that was raised in harlem he
got hit by cars like eight times
nobody gave him love the boat the guy
tied him up there and throws some scraps
and calls them [ __ ] racial slurs and
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying it's one of
those type of dogs that's angry at life
if you're gonna walk into that but then
you gotta walk past that [ __ ] dog
how'd they get business weren't they
biting you have to walk up to the corner
walk down and then creep into the store
on the back and hope the dog ain't
[ __ ] watching if you think i'm
[ __ ] crazy i go in there i buy some
papalito garden a couple coco rico's
because that's what you do when you're
on the upper west side hanging out with
[ __ ] spanish people
i walked back across the street i gave
him darren a coco rico a couple patellas
i started eating like a diamond
how we're gonna start this [ __ ] car
he goes bro every once in a while the
car takes and i start it and we can get
the [ __ ] out of here he goes i just
wanted to tell you no oh he twisted and
didn't [ __ ] think no oh my god we're
on 135th street in amsterdam with
[ __ ] how many i don't know how many
grams of blow on us in a [ __ ] car two
kids with new jersey licenses
so if a cop comes by are you [ __ ]
crazy what are you doing here
what the [ __ ] are you doing here you
dumb [ __ ]
do you guys have drugs no we don't let
me check the [ __ ] car don't make me
go get a [ __ ] dog you know that type
of [ __ ] you're dead you're dead
you're sitting there like so i told him
i said we're dead so we got two choices
we got two choices here
we can sit in here until the [ __ ]
cops come which is no air conditioning
no heat the car's got nothing
we got the windows open or we could go
for a [ __ ] hike and go sit on the
corner stash the blow
and from that pay phone call ups
and call stinky and tell him what's
going on here he's got to pick us up
and that's exactly what we did and we
had to sit on that [ __ ] corner
with the blow hitting in the garbage can
until stinky came over
got us jump started our car
and then stinky who loved fried chicken
kept saying i got to go in there
and he did that i'm standing on the
corner every time he'd go into the
[ __ ] bodega
i'd yell at the dog one more time the
dog would bite stink
and he's thinking stop man stop i didn't
still do nothing because
would he show up in a ups truck
no at this time no he was stupid at this
time he was okay
at this time he was a loader
oh at that time you start as a loader
from 11 to two
and you have to touch a certain amount
of boxes
every hour to get raises 11 pm to 2 a.m
okay that's not bad
when you're a senior and a junior in
high school
that's not a bad job no it started off
at like 10 an hour
oh that's three hours three hours yeah
monday for friday yeah it's 1982 monday
through friday no insurance
and then
he's looking three 15 hours he worked
there for two years and he got hurt
and by that time he had insurance
workman's comp and we used to drive out
the [ __ ] uh
the doctor once a week and he'd get
checked out and get pills we would eat
the [ __ ] pills
there were muscle relaxers they didn't
do dick but we still ate them anyway and
[ __ ]
but this kid rhaego i'm telling you
about here's the funny thing that me and
him lost contact he got in deep
i got in deep i got locked up
and we rekindled our relationship like
in 1991 on the phone
and we got really tight and then i went
back to jersey and this guy was [ __ ]
crazy
like he was one of the few people
that was as crazy as i was like let me
give you an example
like in
1984 there was a cocaine craze in that
whole area there was cocaine grain
across the country
but
there were some colombians who were
going to new york city
and they were taking this
uh
nicotine out of the cigarette half of it
and they would put
cocaine in it and it wouldn't burn right
so people started using
at that time they were going through
everything they were going through free
braised cocaine they were going through
which is just the rocks in the pipe and
[ __ ] but you have to cook the rocks
yourself
with baking soda and that being it's a
bunch of [ __ ] drama a lot of work for
the bang and you go through thousands of
dollars
but these these [ __ ] figured
out that you could get a cup of coffee
you know what cup the the cup you have
at home of course
a mug of coffee you put four fingers of
water in there
you put a gram of [ __ ] coke in there
and you put a little teaspoon or two of
baking soda you put that in your
microwave oven you put 28 seconds bing
it comes out
you go in there with a spoon take out
that little chunk of white [ __ ] you
crack that [ __ ] into a little
powder
you take reefer
you cut that up you get [ __ ] a
rolling paper you put the weed in then
you take that [ __ ] coke
and you sprinkle it in that joint and
you [ __ ]
right tight that joint up real tight and
then you get a lighter and you cook the
cocaine in the joint with that lighter
underneath it you just keep going like
this until the paper
looks like an old newspaper that means
that the coke melted in and they used to
call them bazookas
all right so everybody in new york was
smoking bazookas
that was a lot of work that was bro but
people were taking that pete they would
listen these are savages would hire like
a hot chick
like newton jack city begging what are
you doing tonight nothing listen becky
i've had a crush on you for a long time
what if i gave you what if i gave you
500 for three hours
and you packaged little packages of
baking soda toppers would that work for
you tonight
and you're like what the [ __ ] i ain't
doing nothing better with my life you go
down there and you just wait they would
just you know they'd get girls they'd
get whatever they could
guys you just go you know i'm gonna cook
bazookas i got an ounce of coke
and you would go to somebody's house and
they'd be there somebody would be there
all night putting coke and bacon salad
in the microwave microwave for
twenty-eight every time you heard bing
your whole body would stop jesus christ
wasn't gonna stop banging you know
saying these are too many [ __ ] bigs
what did his neighbor say was like if
you look at an apartment and there's
like this i oh oh it smells like like a
minute
and it smells like that but here's the
professional d was one night
i'm driving on kennedy boulevard zach to
the gills with somebody else
and i look up and i see a guy carrying a
box
i look at my bag oh that looks like
darren
and he goes that is there
we pull over and i look at the box it
wasn't a box it was a microwave on me
with the cord and everything with the
whole cord and i go why do you have a
microwave and he goes listen i don't
want to go to somebody's house and then
i have a microwave oven then we got a
problem you know what i'm saying so
instead he goes the last two places i
went to party to have a microwave oven
and that's [ __ ] who don't have a
microwave oven he had a microwave oven
he carried one everywhere he was yoked
at this time
but that same dude
it was funny because the night
last week i was in utah and before the
late show
i
i got on stage and i told him
like out of the blue i just thought it
did
wow
what the [ __ ] would darren think
that's what i said to myself
and i got off the stage one home got on
the plane came home no bigger deal
the kids were home my wife we played
they went to church i got on facebook
and when i opened facebook there was a
picture down right
and he would have been it was his
birthday
his cousin put the picture up me and his
cousin the tight
his cousin put the picture up in guys it
was like somebody grabbed my lungs
like i just couldn't breathe for a
second when i saw that picture like you
don't see people for a long time
like just to see his image he was there
yo smoking a cigar
and my lungs stopped you know
and you know what bro he had his little
situation in his life and stuff but
this is something a lot of people don't
know about him when i first got into
comedy seriously
the guy who pushed me the most was that
lunatic
and he did some crazy [ __ ] at the comedy
clubs
he did some crazy [ __ ] at comedy clubs
man
like one time he made a dude put me up
on stage
like he walked up to the dude he's like
you put him on stage i'm gonna [ __ ] you
up right here and [ __ ]
and the dude went up on stage and said
somebody just came up to me saying i'll
put this dude up it'll [ __ ] me up
like [ __ ] like that oh my god do you
think you had a moment like on uh
on celia
where she's like always seeing her mom
and then she sees her mom no because
i've been trying when she passed away
that thought of him was like kind of a
no because i've been trying to see
people for 30 years the last time i saw
a spirit i was about
four
five yeah
that's the last time
i thought i saw a [ __ ] spirit but i
was also full who do you see when you're
four you see a lot of creepy [ __ ]
[ __ ] in your mind
at that time i was fried bananas my
father had died my father has died
foreign
yeah my mind was fried bananas
your father goes out one night never
comes back and you're a kid then you're
his [ __ ] right hand
so something
i was broken as it was and one day i
told my mom listen
i saw a spirit in the kitchen which i
really did
i got up in the middle of night and i
saw this [ __ ] image in the kitchen
and he had like a [ __ ] jacket on and
he turned around and that's it and i
just stood there for a second to the
hair and my body stood
and that was it
i never [ __ ]
saw a spirit again 50 years later still
haven't seen one i've been waiting
i've been waiting for somebody to show
up and tap me in the shows in the night
and talk to me and [ __ ]
but even just having thought of him
could have been kind of no that's right
no that's what i accounted for as soon
as i saw that picture i go whoever tells
you no
you know uh
my best friend jimmy burke a couple he's
the one i came out to colorado with
he was taught me and him with tight
he was a great dude i was very lucky to
have him in my life i learned a lot how
to be a friend from him
but he was in the hospital with cancer
and
i kept calling his cell phone you know
what i'm saying i couldn't get a hold
and i knew
i knew it was just a matter of days
before he was gonna die
and
i got a call from him friday
and he called and he [ __ ] pretty much
told me goodbye
and the next day he was gone
and i'm like at least he [ __ ] called
you i'm saying like in my mind i'm like
something makes people do something like
that when carmine balzano died last year
the morning he died he called me when i
was calling him back he didn't answer
and i knew oh that's right you said and
a week later they go coco we looked at
his phone you called him he
you called him 10 minutes later he must
have died right after he hung up which
is [ __ ] creepy
what if he would he would have said
hello
coco was taking him by and he hang ups
the phone he'd [ __ ] die you know i
believe now because i've seen
and felt creepy [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
it's not on that level what about deja
vu and it's not for me it's not usually
with big things it's like little
conversations or things i've seen before
but it's just i like it happens a lot
and i don't think it's stuff that
happened before
it's just really i don't know maybe i'm
maybe i'm crazy but
it happens to me well every few months
really yeah i really like at least every
six months or something yeah it used to
happen to me a lot more when i was
younger
and then as i got older i got out of the
deja vu business but sometimes on an
airport
sometimes
just at weird places
i walking down the aisle of the grocery
store yeah and you'll have one
something random the creepiest thing
before my mom died right across the
street the house that i robbed like four
times
running the puerto rican dude rudy and
the speakers and [ __ ]
well i don't know where some other lady
moved in there
and she was crazy human lady how crazy
is that and she was a black cuban chick
and no no not attractive or anything she
was like in the 50s and stuff
and this is a [ __ ] hilarious story
she would
how big thing that was that she passed
away
she passed the spirit like
every couple [ __ ] nights a week
you know you would hear yelling and
screaming and she'd be at that ball
yelling and stuff like saying [ __ ]
african stuff
how did your uh white catholic neighbors
like that well i you know it's like
embarrassing my mom my mom's like i
don't know this [ __ ] lady you know
what i'm saying like
why do you you know because she was
cuban so
so my mom went over the doctor and stuff
and
and one night dawg this [ __ ] i'm i'm
coming up the corner
and she's out there my daughter's like a
spirit come back in the house oh my god
she talks to like a dog no like that she
would talk to her like the spirit
like she knew it was a spirit in her
mother's body her mother would be out
there barefoot walking on glass and [ __ ]
yelling in african terms like out in the
street the spirit that entered her
wanted to go outside and yell at people
and talk to people oh my god i'll never
forget this dog
i saw her
i was 15 16 i didn't make eye contact
with her i kept walking up the hill
and this [ __ ] started yelling at me
like oh
hello
oh like in this weird language she
crossed the street halfway
and as i was putting mike in those days
i could either walk up those three
stairs
or i had the garage keys i could put my
key in the garage we had the old school
juice and you just pick up the garage
and the car is picking up the garage
she says
she goes hey
your father has a message for you
dog i shut that [ __ ] garage door
ran upstairs i mean you know [ __ ] like
that stay for the moment you didn't get
the message
what was the message
i didn't stay for the message but it's
my my dead dad
a [ __ ] uh 10 years he's really gonna
send me a message guys well would you
how would you know you your dad wasn't
alive this is the question that's what
i'm saying you should this is the
question that has always haunted me
i never told my mom i never don't know
but you know [ __ ] like that happens
sometimes do you ever believe in lucky
coincidences always they have to have a
life yeah you know so lucky coincidences
huh
i don't want to see your spirit i don't
want to go to a [ __ ] seance
when i was a kid i grew up around that
i grew up on that side of cuban
stuff
because they always felt that since my
dad had died
he was kind of like at night
there's nights mercy crawls in the bed
with us
and it's a long [ __ ] night of sleep
because she likes to sleep she sleeps
again
but it's not that it's how many [ __ ]
times she moves asleep
so like if my mom was still alive and
saw that
by now she would got to see this old
lady he went through cards for her or
[ __ ] seaweed seeds
and told her what bothered this little
girl and it could be a relative
of 10 years it could be somebody who's
not letting this child sleep
nine out of 10 they just make you put a
glass of water under the bed
all right and that works number one they
make you put a glass of water under your
bed and if you talk in your sleep
you have to put your right slipper
over your left slipper
i've never heard that one that's as deep
as cuban as it gets so for these
[ __ ] let's say you you're
banging the [ __ ] boss and your
husband don't know you don't want to
talk in your sleep do you
so you put the right shoe over the left
shoe
oh my god
if your husband touches you talking to
your sleeve and you're sucking the
boss's dick you got to put the right
drill in the live stream and you'll be
fine
oh my god that's how [ __ ] cuban
superstitious my family was what about i
think i had a few of them but not that
what about like the i mean
like the whole animal sacrifice part
like did that mess you up as a kid i
mean
um
it was a secret that i had amongst
myself
i never told none of my friends
but then as i grew up i've learned about
all these other
in israel they killed chickens yeah they
they swing them around by their necks
you know it's it's great it's crazy
everybody everybody somewhere around
there
has to kill something a goat i don't
have
everyone every god requires a different
animal yeah they used to in the in the
bible their sheep and all right there's
no cats
there's no [ __ ] dogs
there's no [ __ ] gorillas
monkey yes
monkey yes some saints require a monkey
that's a key monkey yeah some science
requirement but not like every [ __ ]
day and who's got money for a [ __ ]
monkey i'm saying these people trying to
get their life together now you gotta
throw a curveball out of them
and you're gonna get to keep it and do
fun monkey things yeah
and anyway you gotta get like a little
monkey and kill him and [ __ ] my friend
had a monkey in his bathroom one time
for santoria purposes when i was about
eight he was a gay dude uh i don't think
i don't know what his name is now but
[ __ ] years i never forget that dude
you couldn't go to the bathroom i was
like hey i'm there with my mom and my
[ __ ] santa ray godmother and she's
like coco's gotta pee you need to go to
the no we can't go that one there's a
monkey in there like there's a monkey in
there he's like you want to see him he
opened up he had like blue hair and [ __ ]
i ran the [ __ ] out of there like what do
you want to do with the monkey he goes
the saint wants a monkey
[ __ ] you you got him from like the like
those shampoo testing places when they
were done with them i don't know i don't
know what the [ __ ] they got him what do
you think i'm gonna ask questions i
don't know how else a monkey would have
died blue hair it was [ __ ] seven all
i want is a [ __ ] little pace and get
the [ __ ] out of here are there fancy
monkeys that have blue hair oh i'm sure
there are yeah there must be something
they're like you know birds
the animal stuff didn't bother me oh i
see how you're asking me
at first i didn't have to uh
really look or be involved
and then the more i went
as a child you have to
you know
like i rose and ranked
yeah
you know i'm saying like i rose and
ranks well they're not gonna show like a
three-year-old like no nothing but they
must now all these things i went there
for i understood what was going on
you understand me guys i understood i
knew at the age of six becky
that i wasn't like regular kids that was
six
i knew something wasn't right
i'm not gonna tell you i knew it was my
dad i knew something was missing
so when i hooked up with my godmother at
the age of four
i liked her like i liked her
she never said nothing to me about
santeria she would tell me stories about
catholicism
okay and how they wrapped up with
santorini
and the stories were great and then she
showed me her saints and she did
and i said to her and she goes because
when you're a kid you like the the
[ __ ] beads
you follow me
so you like the beads
so i would get like a bead and then
she'd tell me the story of that saint
and that's how i got involved with it
and then on sundays if i was there
she'd be cooking like you know a shared
job was the
[ __ ] people would come there all the
time to do services
so when i wasn't with her
i'd be outside playing and i would walk
in there from time to time and they'd be
killing a goat or a [ __ ]
a lamb or a couple chickens or a pigeon
or a turkey
they'd kill a bunch of different birds
and in those days they used to drive to
marlborough new jersey to pick up the
animals which was like a three hour
drive four hour it was like a half a
night drive
and they would come back and then
then when i got into the religion
that was
where uh
it was [ __ ] wild
it was wild the animals like the you
know
the night that you got initiated there's
a lot of animals dog
you know yeah yeah sheep
they got a couple of them the ones with
the horns the ones without the horn
maybe the saint wants the horns you
never you know it's [ __ ] crazy did
they sacrifice them all for you
not for [ __ ] me
the ceremony the ceremony yeah now for
me
it was for the ceremony
but you have to be up all night it was
tremendous
so this day i sit there and i'm like wow
i can't believe i sat there and i
enjoyed i still remember getting out of
there
going to school on monday and they
wouldn't let me go to school with a
white hat on
why
because the school teacher said you have
to take your hat off and i might
complain i was completely bald
and my mom went in there and went into
the room with the principal game like
500 bucks you were wearing a hat and i
was wearing a [ __ ] hat this school
wasn't that simple [ __ ] crazy
no it seems like
a century's like a personal like are
there churches or is it all like your
family and your friends form little
group former groups i was raised in the
old school santoria
where you keep it to yourself without a
bicycle selling
not knocking on doors yeah we're not
knocking on doors
but now and i think in my world
in my world it's it's not like
i loved it
i knew it was me i love going to
catholic church i love all that [ __ ]
but at the same time
i never thought i wanted to make a
living doing it
like not at one point in my life well
not even a living i just meant for like
the santeria aspect of it was there are
there churches where you can go and do
these ceremonies and i don't know i
don't know they're probably more like
people's houses yeah that's us yeah it's
people's houses yeah right okay there's
no
i don't i've never heard of a church
like a place to the only church i heard
it was the church of what's happening
now [ __ ]
nice segway [ __ ] that's that's the
way to do it
that's my girl becky from matt
therapy and [ __ ]
what else has been going on you hurt
yourself you're preparing for ebi i'm
for the qualifier yeah what is it
june like 11th or 12th
okay
i'm surprised you're not at her door at
six am joey just with like the golf cart
to like make a run
eggs to swallow look at look at becky's
pants i know if you're at becky's house
at six in the morning i ain't gonna
watch a run you know what i'm saying is
to watch your [ __ ] do jumping jacks
or something like that
all creepy in the corner becca just do
jumping jacks
and just watch and sweat you know what
i'm saying
we've been doing jumping jacks for six
weeks joey what's going on
it's a shame you're working really hard
yeah i could feel in your voice when we
spoke the first time but you know
it's a lot it's a lot of
it's a lot in your body i mean i was
training
four days a week
jiu-jitsu four days a week and then
strength and conditioning three days a
week
so that's fine man that's a lot finally
i had a muscle just say [ __ ] you and i'm
not doing this anymore you know
like sometimes i go gg to two uh two
weeks
in a row i go three times
plus that sunday
which is light yeah and guess what like
it catches you feel it yeah you feel it
and i have to stay at home and work out
a day and stretch a little more and
stuff
but uh four times a week that's a big
time commitment man that's big
and eventually the more times you go the
higher the percentages of you hurting an
arm getting a hand they jacked up my
wrist today he caught me on this roll
this kid tucked my wrist it
it was it was i could feel the wrist
about to just fall off
he was gonna take it with him and [ __ ]
i'm getting old that bone will break
right away from that skin
the funny thing i didn't get hurt during
jiu-jitsu no no i was doing like a
simple workout and just
so how much longer your rehabbing
so it gets better though it feels better
where did you guys do the podcast last
week
l.a jiu jitsu club
and ho gen 3
the guys from l.a jiu-jitsu club joey
huss joey haas yeah eric medina eric
eric showed up later so he wasn't well
i'd like to congratulate he got engaged
in hawaii to bonnie staley
like to congratulate
eric medina and bonnie staley they got
engaged in hawaii over the week or just
yesterday and the day before today i
think even i think
if you're if you're in [ __ ] l.a to
watch comedy and you like to roll check
out the la jiu jitsu hotel they got the
it's cool and [ __ ] joey haas is up there
medina they got another guy from 10th
planet up there you go up there two in
the morning and there's people [ __ ]
rolling pretty much yeah it's 24 because
uh that one of them works in the morning
and one of them works nights yeah so
there's always someone there to be able
to have like seven classes there isn't
like the dining room just mats now yeah
that's crazy that's how it's always been
they have like a living room area with
some couches
and then the dining room
is all mats
they have a lot of room they have a pool
they have like a lot of spots where
people like they yeah they've had teams
stay there so it's at the la jiu-jitsu
club it's pretty cool yeah it's pretty
awesome it's like a little hostel you
don't have to go anywhere you can just
and they'll leave now they even like
take people to training
at certain places like they'll take
people to hq they'll take people to jean
jock's
or wherever they want to go
and here's what also i love about
jiu-jitsu i watch a lot of the guys
i'm a watcher dog
sometimes
i roll twice and i know my limitations
you know i'm not gonna roll four times
yeah i'll take a roll off
and i'll roll the third time until the
class ends yeah and then you go right
into a warm-up
you're following me but here's the
beauty
well i'm sitting against the wall
and i'm breathing i'm watching
and i'm watching the guys
so you start getting really strong in
jiu jitsu your body starts to get
adjusted to it
and all of a sudden you start getting
stronger
which means you start going a little
harder yeah
i see the progression
you get comfortable and then one day
you see them come in with a bandage on
their [ __ ] head
or a [ __ ] cast on their arm
or a knee with whatever and you're like
what happened like i was here rolling
one night and they popped my knee on a
leg block and you sit there and go you
know what and it's funny i've been
watching these guys how
the system goes and it's like
you come in
you love it
you know
there's limitations and then one day you
break away from the limitation and
you're in that jiu jitsu parlor every
time every day every class you don't
miss a [ __ ] class you love it you eat
breathe whatever you did to
and you get strong and at that time
you're getting stronger and stronger and
stronger and once you get that first
belt jesus [ __ ] christ if you thought
you loved it before you're loving it now
as a matter of fact you're not gonna go
back to work you're gonna get your
pension your 401k you're just gonna
[ __ ] train you know it's the fun and
all of a sudden
you start getting more and more involved
which you're supposed to
which you're [ __ ] supposed to
well um
becky i mean you you obviously still
work but you
you've had a few different jobs since
i've known you and
haven't you decided to like focus more
on jiu-jitsu than on that aspect of your
life
i went through the exact same path that
he basically just just uh talked about
i had i had the job that
paid paid well just didn't leave me time
to train much so i had to get it you
know something that would allow me the
time
to spend and then little by little i
just got more and more consumed i wanted
to do more not just jiu jitsu how else
can i involve it
you know i think of being 21 to 28
and wanting a job that paid a lot of
money because
the primary focus was money
by the time i got on stage the first
time i was 32 or 31 i knew
that money wasn't necessary it took me
all those years to realize that i was
chasing the wrong [ __ ] dream
you know i had a high school education a
couple semesters in college who the [ __ ]
was i getting
you know i could sell my ass off
whatever you got
i'll take a job against your little
college students i guarantee i'll smoke
these [ __ ]
i'll smoke them and smoke them over they
won't know they're coming in here with a
[ __ ] degree in business
i'll eat them up the last four years
i've been selling belly-to-belly sales
[ __ ]
cars pipes
bazookas grams of blow i'm hitting you
from every [ __ ] aspect you getting
postcards on your birthday you know what
i'm saying i'm that dude
so
what the [ __ ] are we talking about
anyway no no no i'm sorry
when you realize that comedy you do it
for yeah that you [ __ ] uh one day you
go [ __ ] it
i want to do what makes me happy yeah
you know and the rent i'll
the the two thousand dollar car payment
i'll [ __ ] sell the car and get myself
a [ __ ] bicycle okay
because all i need to do is go to jiu
jitsu and my job is three blocks away
you start downsizing yeah you know what
that two bedroom i don't need it that
bedroom i don't need no [ __ ] office
tell a landlord to put me in a [ __ ]
studio you know and all of a sudden on
and on you just learn limitations yeah
when i left boulder in 95
the car was what i could afford
the car cost me 600 [ __ ] dollars that
was gonna be
my apartment
my office
for life
that was my investment that was the last
of every [ __ ] dime
i borrowed for [ __ ] that car
i didn't care my rent was 35 a month for
the pager and gasoline
i had a page that's how you got a hold
of me that's it
there was nothing i got a calling card
for 10 bucks
and you're trying to make it work that's
all he is that's it you're breaking for
comedy what are you gonna do
how much you gonna make in the beginning
you're scrapping on 50s if you can pop
together three fifties if you could pop
together six fifties what's that that's
300 that's it that's the first month of
comedy welcome to comedy [ __ ] what
are you gonna do with 300 hours that's
gasoline you have a couple cocktails
maybe one night you got a hotel your
sister puts you up for three days you
know because someone has you got breaks
in between yeah and the same thing
happens there and they tell you after
like a week and a half so what are you
gonna do you're gonna get a job you're
like not really i want the jiu jitsu
thanks for the time
i want to be a comedian and they look at
you like are you [ __ ] crazy it's not
gonna work out that's a long road any
road you're going to take is going to be
[ __ ] low you know look at your wife
now she got drive to [ __ ]
ball heights starting on [ __ ] monday
every day
what do you want to suck yeah what are
you going to do you know that's that's
where you started rush hour
that's where you happen in 20 years
she'll take the helicopter to the ball
yeah i mean dude i can't tell you how
great it was not having to drive the 405
twice a day
yeah
i did that for
two three years that was terrible that
was awful that's the other option
so yeah see you got options here and
both of them are [ __ ] bad yeah yeah
so you got to pick what's your worst
poison what's the one that's going to
kill me and least the [ __ ] at
least i'll enjoy the death yeah like
that's uh
i already had a very interesting podcast
this and it was with like someone who
was within thailand who like an
australian guy who uh
has been running like a cave
hotel almost like a cave exploring hotel
in thailand for 30 years from australia
just never left thailand
and it's it's weird they were talking
about how it's
why do you spend all that time at work
to pay for all that stuff if you can't
do or see anything you can't enjoy it so
i mean
how how did your parents
react to you lowering your job or lower
like changing your focus my mom still
gives me a hard time yeah
all right
my dad you know he's do what makes you
happy kind of person right
but
my mom to this day every she's like when
are you going to get a job
when are you going to get the you know
she wants she she thinks i need to get a
you know monday through friday nine to
five job that has insurance does she
send you like job postings she did once
thank god she doesn't do it that often
but she did send me one she's like did
you see it and i ignored it and like two
weeks later
my doctor and she goes by the way did
you see that job listing that i sent you
yeah i'm like yeah but i ignored it
i'm just thinking about when i made that
decision like i was like
wow i'm separated now
you know they're not they're not going
to hire me as a roofer no more they told
me they were moving the company back to
jersey
that meant a lot of money i went to the
other roofing companies in the area and
they offered me half
of what i was making as a roofer
and i'm like wow i'm [ __ ] dead
like i'm dead
i'm like i go back and sell cars like oh
we don't want i really want to do
camping
i just started selling [ __ ] dog
i just went all out
i knew what i didn't want anymore [ __ ]
this
and that was it
you just downsized to start all over
again
i was living out of a car
from june of 95 to [ __ ]
i had that car till probably 96
then they towed that [ __ ] up
up in seattle washington they towed your
home yeah no no but at that time i had
an apartment oh okay but the [ __ ]
bumper had fallen off it it was a datsun
dog a four-door datsun my dad had one of
them that was a tank of debt
that car had taken me from colorado to
baltimore probably eight times colorado
michigan probably 10 times
and then over and over and over and over
from colorado to washington state
down to oregon
zip over california back to colorado
yeah no it was a tank and all this car
ever needed was for me to fix the
radiator
everyone wants someone to put the metal
in there so it wouldn't leak
the only thing this car needed was a
little oil once a week
gasoline and love
this car
600 bucks bro this car was it
i couldn't even believe it one time the
frame broke
the [ __ ] frame broke in ogallala
nebraska
all right i was coming back from
michigan i had picked up 450 for three
days
at joey's comedy club in dearborn
michigan
that was one of the most embarrassing
situations in my [ __ ] life
because i met a woman
but i was in michigan and stuff
and i lingered there
until monday
and at that time
i was whatever old i was and by that
time my shoulders were starting to hurt
i wasn't at that point
once i left boulder
i had a weight set in my living room so
i lifted weights every night after
calmly or before i went out to do con
i did basic stretches bent over rows i
didn't have dumbbells or a lap machine
but i did bent over rows and all that
stuff well after i moved out of boulder
my shoulders started hurting because of
lack of activity
and i'll never forget that in michigan
i saw a place of similar size and i
pulled up
and i guess i ring the door and this is
how dumb i was back in that one of the
girls the girl comes out and she's
[ __ ] gorgeous
hi how are you what do you like i got
massage
what's the matter my shoulders in really
bad shape
i just need somebody to rub my shoulder
and next thing you know she goes all
right hold on walk back here
she takes her back to this room and this
lady comes back there
she leaves
tells me to get naked
there's no way i'm getting naked
like i'm one of those dudes that's not
[ __ ] happening
for me to get a naked you got to get
naked
or not i ain't getting [ __ ] naked let
me know what you need and i'll help you
out but i just ain't taking off my pants
because you're telling me to get naked
just
the [ __ ] little lady comes back
this is not the most best looking woman
i like if the lucy lou would have came
back the chick from the counter we could
have a little party
but this [ __ ] nasty [ __ ] there's no
way
let's lose grandma and she looks at me
she's like lay down lay down i'm like i
don't want to lay down i just want my
shoulder up i can sit right here rub my
shoulder put ben gay on my shoulder
and she's like [ __ ] no no no no you
gotta lay down you know lay down and she
couldn't close me and finally she looks
at me she goes lay down and i give you a
hen jump three dollars and i look to
them i go
what the [ __ ] are you thinking get the
[ __ ] out i ran out and i was pissed for
two hours
that somebody would charge you 30
dollars to give me a [ __ ] hand job
that's disgusting that's like
people do it for each other for free you
know
30 [ __ ] dollars to give me a hand job
with that krusty [ __ ] ant oh oh my
god knows where the [ __ ] it's been
so now i'm cutting through
whatever
i pulled down [ __ ] nebraska i'm an
ogallala i'll go over
boom
something happens to the [ __ ] car
i pull over i got a flat tire
right behind me in that the rear tire on
the driver's side
i jacked the car up
i got a spare and i got another spare in
there too you know me though i got a
spare and i got the bicycle tire
so i put the spare around that bar
but put the jack in the trunk drink some
water whatever soda i get back in the
car bloom i started up again
the car is feeling weird
and awesome
after about 10 minutes are you again
like what the [ __ ] i got another flat
tire
same one same [ __ ] one the rear sight
what the [ __ ]
again i jacked the car up i put the
bicycle tire on this [ __ ]
and the bicycle tire lit on fire like it
melted it was like that rubber
that [ __ ] creepy rubber
it just flattened from melting
and i finally a guy pulled over
oh no here we go uh
i sat there and last night i start
walking
there's no cell phones nothing like that
i start walking
and within 10 minutes a girl pulls up
how did the [ __ ] with a little white
dress on this [ __ ]
when i got in the car she started
driving she went to make a turn and a
bush of hair came out from under a
[ __ ] armpit
if you understand me like i was looking
at like maybe this could be the [ __ ]
night of my life
my car blows up but i got the best piece
of dirty white ass i've ever gotten in
my life in north carolina nebraska
by this time i have like 350 dollars in
my pocket
and then she tells me no no no we'll get
the car towed and you go back to the
commune
and i'm like what come here she goes we
want to come here for christians come on
up there you can spend a few days and
relax
you can meet my husband this chicks had
no bra
with a see-through like [ __ ]
tremendous this only happened to uncle
joe
i saw that bush here and christians i
got the [ __ ] out of the car
i got the tow truck i told the frame
broke on the [ __ ] car that's the only
thing that ever happened to that datsun
my dad had a datsun
i melted a crayon in the back seat once
i left it on the seat
it was a purple crane
that's all i got
well what are you gonna do there's
always got a story about the dachshund
do you
i have known stories about dartmouth
like that's all part of comedy i'm
pretty sure those were gone by the time
you were born like when you first start
you're not making a lot of money but
your car breaks down yeah from all the
[ __ ] driving
yeah you gotta include that in the
budget there's never a budget like that
for a breakdown that's the part of i
don't understand
like i'm not sure how homeless people
keep it together to be honest
like well they're homeless because they
can't keep it together well no but i'm
like i'm like can you believe this
[ __ ] guy no no let me finish okay
like when you are starting comedy right
and you have to go buy a car and they're
gouging you on every corner and then
your rent goes up
the next day every year and they're
grabbing you on that and it's just like
i'm lucky enough that i can afford it
right now are you talking about my life
i'm talking about my my rent just went
up seventy five bucks hey mike with
three weeks
oh yeah so i'm kind of i'm i'm thinking
about causing a stink for a month but
we'll see at least push it back another
month that's why that i think mine
started starts in june i go up 75.
and and i just bought a new car that
huge uh tax bill that i have yeah i got
i've never heard of this happening to
anyone in the history of the irs
i got 200 back because they calculated
something wrong like i i didn't ask for
it they just sent it so i'm gonna go
there now that i feel like i feel like i
paid way more than i should have whoa
so yeah i don't think i've ever heard so
but my point was is
when you can't afford it
when you can't wait like how do you keep
going how do you why
like how are you still doing comedy
rather than selling drugs and like in
your case or something
everybody's level of
being able to keep going is different
he had a
he had a higher tolerance
i know what it's like to be in a
basement
with no money you owe 800
to one guy
you owe 600 1600 to another guy
you probably got 32 hours in your pocket
you've been up for three [ __ ] days oh
my god
your pager is [ __ ] on fire
you know people are looking for you for
coke people want to buy coke
people want you to sell them coke
and the people you owe money to [ __ ]
calling you nonstop
you have no idea you're in the basement
and you got eight hours and you're
sleeping with a [ __ ] old blanket that
smells like dog piss
and a mattress with no cover on it you
know
you have no [ __ ] idea you know when
you're in that
and you you go to bed and you wake up
and there's no water you gotta go
outside and pee in by the garage and you
know
it's horrible
there's no end
you get yourself into a cycle that is
endless
i got into a cycle that was [ __ ]
endless
and no matter what i robbed and no
matter what lie i told myself and no
matter how much money i made
i'd always blow it
my goal was to have two thousand dollars
i could rob that in one hour from a
hotel room some people stash and blow
at nine out of ten i did
but did i get the apartment
no
why would i it was too easy if i did
this one i get the apartment next week
for now i sleep on lee's couch
or i rent a hotel room in a roach hotel
and you know what i'll rent the hotel
for a hundred dollars for the week
i don't need the money i paid today
right what's today wednesday the
wednesday yeah i don't need to even
think about rent on next wednesday
i'm not thinking about rental tuesday
[ __ ] night at 11 o'clock at night
when i leave in the morning what story
i'm gonna tell this guy and what time
i'm coming back with his yardstick
do you when you're that deep into
addiction
are you upset at yourself for being that
like in that position it doesn't even
lie that doesn't even seem weird to you
like you'd like to when i was 20 or two
years old i was in the hotel in fort lee
new jersey
it was a hotel where people took people
to have sex
by the hour
no not by the hours a little bit classy
yeah it was by the george washington
very much
offer
i think it was route 4 and the good
thing was if you walked down the hill a
little bit there was a grand union
that made the best lobster best you ever
had back here you understand i'm so
hungry right now when you buy a loaf of
bread forget about it
i could just imagine
i'm gonna imagine her right here right
now
no you can't eat the [ __ ] office
so jiu-jitsu like
drugs only so jiu-jitsu is really kind
of blowing up right now like who's this
guy like marvin seberus i don't even
know how to like pronounce his name but
i just see him rolling around on the
floor doing crazy [ __ ] cerberus is his
uh nickname okay
okay i'm sorry i apologize he's uh he's
uh he's one of my teammates yeah yeah
like yeah and he has like he has like it
looks like he has like sponsors on his
on his rash guard that's right
well
it just seemed like it just seems like
it's really blowing up right now yeah
well his video did
that in our he hit at a fight to win
so it was pretty impressive
although he hit another
one at uh the abcc trials that i enjoyed
more
and more
there's like there's like a really big
uh
and i mean i don't know if it's an
industry but there's a lot of jiu jitsu
videos i see online like why did that
one like really explode because it
looked cool to me but i don't know
jujitsu
exactly that's i think that's the reason
is because even to someone that doesn't
that doesn't know they saw that and
they're like whoa that was cool
yeah i know he was flipping around and
he yeah
he's really uh
and it's it's not that's not a move that
people do you don't see that very often
i don't i don't see it very often so i
think to
to see something that you rarely see and
to hit you know to have someone hit it
so smoothly and so quickly
i think that's
and then like there's a lot of people
like what a guy uh i just saw him on
instagram and he's like he's in europe
doing seminars there's people like
traveling the world
just teaching seminars that's really
cool
they have that access now like where
isn't eddie in like career or something
right now or like he's going to be going
there i know they're doing like a
training camp out there that's crazy um
is it is it korea oh yeah south korea
right yeah they posted something
yesterday yeah yeah i keep seeing it
yeah there's like this big training camp
thing or something yeah
and see if the missiles are real they're
really lit duds that is what he's gonna
do i'm going over there to make sure the
koreans are telling the truth
not a conspiracy and [ __ ] you think he's
you don't think he's gonna go try and
creep up into north carolina [ __ ] yeah
he's gonna try to schedule a meeting
see if it really was up did you see a
picture he posted the other day of uh
i don't know what it was but it looked
like the bat cave like this picture that
was supposedly from north korea and like
all the work that they're doing or
whatever i don't know no and the picture
looks like
a scene from uh
the batman tv show you know like really
cheesy like
equipment and stuff that's totally what
it looked like
that's funny
well let's hope that's not let's hope
it's as cheesy as it looks
right
no kidding
no kidding so mother's day what are you
guys doing with your mom's what are you
doing baby you going down there i am yep
what about you leaves and flowers or
anything i have to call tomorrow some
flowers i already have a card out oh
your job is quick and easy just send
flowers
yeah well
well i i i i i went i think maybe uh
two mother's days ago or her birthday
because it's they're a week they're a
week apart um but i was here at some
point this summer my mom's like a couple
weeks apart from her birthday and
mother's day yes
uh
no i'm going down to
have dinner with my uncle's house on
saturday
you just said flowers online like no i
don't do i i it's probably an app that
doesn't uh no honestly i don't to be
honest
you call in i have to i haven't found
uh i haven't found there's a couple that
have done okay jobs that i that
sometimes i'll use in a hurry but if i
have time i call a place because i feel
like they do a better job
like a mom pop shop out there or
something i found one near her
house but she because she used to work
from home how often are you sending
flowers by the way sounds like you're
sending them a lot mother's day
and uh
valentine's day oh you're doing
everything okay now here's how
superstitious uncle joey is
all right this week i'm going to
milwaukee
right
and then saturday and when i get up and
i fly to detroit
detroit
bring those little pants and [ __ ] let's
go
well sunday morning is mother's day
the last time i got stuck
was in grand rapids michigan flying out
of [ __ ] lane detroit
so i already prepared it i might be a
little late i might get stuck it might
be a [ __ ] tornado
you never know it's a direct flight
right
so
i got options
so i'm sitting down for breakfast this
morning the whole family's eating
breakfast
and mercy starts talking to terry about
some [ __ ]
and she goes
for mother's day
i'm gonna get you a bunch of flowers
would you like that
and i could see it through terry off for
a minute it was like terry getting
punched in the [ __ ] stomach
so i said you know what just in case
i'm gonna go get a flowers deliver to
the house
in case something [ __ ] up happens on
sunday but here's the beauty of it i
went to pick up the [ __ ] kid
yesterday the babysitter babysits on
date night for us came up to the car
yesterday she goes joey what are you
guys doing sunday or nothing
and she goes i want to babysit for free
i want to get you guys out of the house
that's how cool this chick is
she's 19 mercy loves her she loves mercy
what the [ __ ] you gonna do
they love each other they [ __ ] watch
tv
that's nice of her yeah she's really
cool too so do you have time
yeah she's a good lady so do you have
plans have you made plans no my dad's uh
the principal of the school
no i mean for for sunday not yet
not yet what's with the questions i got
no [ __ ] plans you know me by the
mother's day you're not gonna get a
reservation now unless you know
so maybe i'll just go to starbucks take
her out for pizza
sometimes don't give me some of your
points at morton's like be some morning
points to get a reservation
those people don't talk to me though you
got to be [ __ ] the guitar player from
the foo fighters or
you got to be something like that at
mornings they don't want to don't
[ __ ] give a [ __ ] about comedians or
podcasts or anything like that no no not
like that i'm just saying like you have
like like the
points card what points card i got no
point i don't know nobody even what's
the point if you're sold out what's my
point excuse me
they threw the chinese guy off the plane
how many points you thought he had
if they put that poor chinese guy off
the plane i guarantee that guy gets i
think it's on points
did you see that fight on southwest i
burped in here
yeah
no oh yeah it was bad it was worse
people were fighting on the plane
i've never seen that in my life i didn't
see the whole thing i just saw people
they were going on two white guys
but it wasn't like
airport employees or anything it was
just passengers right right yeah what
were they fighting about i don't know i
didn't
i just don't understand how quick these
people could [ __ ] get a camera out
and tape these fights they got me
something's going on here it takes two
seconds they were probably screaming at
each other already before the fight
started that's right you're a genius see
me i can't believe these people just pop
a [ __ ] camera why is there so many
things going on on planes lately
people like funny that's like the thing
right now
everybody's gonna go start
starting fights on an airplane now just
to record them and
well again i have to hit you with the
[ __ ] stupid age card
and how long i've been flying i used to
fly into california when i was seven by
myself
did you know that becky 1960 okay in
those days the airline system you paid
for a plane thinking you were a kid
they just put you in first class
okay first class used to be half full
there was always a big [ __ ] space
i remember getting on planes to be a
piano player
did you know that no
with a pig
with an apple in his [ __ ] mouth
and it'd be surrounded with cheeses and
crackers
and they'd be playing [ __ ] pianos
if you watch the movie midnight run
when they get on a plane it's a
two-decker plane
that was 1980 [ __ ] six 87 there were
two decker planes it was in the 80s i
thought like the six years that was in
72 if you wanted to party you come
upstairs
let me tell you something i remember
taking red eyes because i was a coke
fiend you know why
because word on the street was if you're
doing drugs you took the red eye
you know how many parties i went on the
[ __ ] red eye and had the best times
of my life you have any [ __ ] idea
how many red eyes i went on that it was
just dirty people [ __ ] up
drinking talking [ __ ] and you get there
and now you're in a bar with them
next you know you're at their house
you know you know how [ __ ] crazy that
is
now
now you got a red eye
and from the minute you get on the plane
they turn the lights off you're going to
sleep whether you [ __ ] want to or not
yet and you can't put on your little
light because nobody else could sleep so
you're the only [ __ ] in your room
with your light on
so you gotta sit there with your
computer with earphones on and
not bother you know it's a [ __ ]
nightmare
it's a [ __ ] nightmare so changing has
become flying has become this
and now for the last seven years i've
been playing
i've been flying pretty steady
and
what i've seen
across the board is [ __ ] horrific
i mean i know what i'm paying for my
plane ticket and it's [ __ ] horrific
i ignore it because it's a part of me
doing business right you have to pick
your wars
i picked the flights
i always pick the first flights which i
have the best percentages
i do different [ __ ] things
i know what airports to get an extra
better ticket
i know what airport i'm gonna get an
upgrade from
i know how to scam the [ __ ] system
and i'm pretty good at it but it's all
because i've been doing it
you know before that i was flying
but flying on the cuff
so a club would give me a plane ticket
and i was racking up miles i couldn't
because they bought it on price that
line
you know when you get a ticket on
price.line and you take it to the
airlines they're not [ __ ] happy with
you
the airline will put you on last just on
purpose next to that big black dude
boarding like zone six or something yeah
zone 22
and you're right next to the bathroom
and people are farting and [ __ ]
their head
and then you are in the seat by yourself
but you're inhaling [ __ ] debt
by the time you get off you feel like
ted bundy
[ __ ] happily electrocuted them or
whatever so
you know that that was this level of
commitment and fly i remember being in
first class and you went into the
bathroom and there was creams
there was cologne there was perfume for
women
you could take some and wipe it down or
you could take it for later
there was a time when there was more
commitment to the people and they
weren't charging that much
then all of a sudden the plane heights
get up
then they said we're raising the price
of fuel
[Music]
because of the price of fuel we have to
collect on the
luggage
25 for a piece of luggage
so for the common american who's
fighting for his [ __ ] life
knowing how to pay for that plane ticket
but if they take two pieces of the
luggage that's 50 there and 50 back so
any plane ticket you better tack on a
yardstick
any [ __ ] plane ticket and for some
people it's a by the way they don't even
know what's happening till they get to
the [ __ ] airport it's like 25 hours
what are you [ __ ] nuts are you
[ __ ] crazy i'll carry this [ __ ] out
and we'll throw away your shampoos
it's not gonna fit
you know so this is and then after 9 11
you want to complain about tsa but
listen they're trying to do the best to
keep us [ __ ] uh
from blowing up in the [ __ ] skies
so you got to wait those 10 minutes
some cities don't have enough tsa and a
lot of traffic you're going to wait a
[ __ ] hour
i know in those places
to get a business select tickets
something that'll get me through that
gate i can wear sweatpants so i don't
have no drama
i got sneakers with orthotics in it just
in case i got to be on my feet you know
this is what people got to [ __ ] think
about man
flying isn't easy no more
and and going back to what i was talking
about earlier you feel like you're
getting jammed i feel like
airlines are probably one of the biggest
places and the most like accessible
because people are right there
and like there used to be choice now
there's no choice and they know it and
they jack up the prices at the holidays
and at terrible times and it's just it's
a
it's not a fun experience anymore at all
you know if you're a regular american
that's fighting for their lives and
you're not experienced in flying
you know you're not experiencing flying
you don't know the loopholes through
airports
a [ __ ] flying is is overwhelming it's
[ __ ] overwhelming that you think
you're going into a battle zone
and then you get there you stop for a
bottle of water and they tell you four
dollars they look you straight in the
face and you look at them like jesus
christ
jesus christ
four dollars it's not only you banging
me on the [ __ ] flight now let me tell
you something unless you're at kennedy
and you're eating at the palms or you're
in newark new jersey and you're eating
at that [ __ ] uh
that crab cake house and there's a
couple other airports if i don't mention
you i'm sorry boston you have legals
your boston has legals you're basically
eating [ __ ] dick when you get home
about two hours later a shit's gonna
come out of your ass and you're gonna
look at it and smell and go what
happened i gotta go lay down i'm sick
yeah those eggs on that biscuit those
are [ __ ] eggs made with whatever was
left over and powder
you know powder and [ __ ] eggs don't
that those eggs those powdered eggs
that's why i always look for the place i
want to see the yolk
i want to see the yolk i don't want no
misunderstandings here i don't want no
flip over patty that you think i'll you
know these places you go to the subway
and they just put it in there oh that's
the eggs are the worst you don't want
scrambled right because then it's all
blended i want to see that because let
me see
there's no misunderstanding
if i want to see scrambled eggs i'll ask
for scrambled eggs the menu says you got
yolk yeah
let me see the [ __ ] yolk i want to
see the [ __ ] yolk so i'm happy all
right don't break that [ __ ] yoke
because if you break that [ __ ] you're
gonna have a problem too last week i
went to arrest a hotel
that
i like the hotel
but that kitchen sucks dick
the breakfast ain't bad because they
have eggs and they they show you the
yolk they broke this
they broke the [ __ ] yogurt
and there were two samoan kids and they
were second cousins
one guy was a big samoan like he was in
the starter package he was like 3 10
but next time i see him before 18
and after that he'll put 900 [ __ ]
pounds his feet won't fit in his shoes
it'll be huge but his cousin
looked
like
goldberg
what's the you know entourage
what's his name nobody knows what i'm
talking mikey wahlberg what's his name
turtle no no wolberg yeah donnie walberg
which one's done
which one's done donnie's the uh mark
the older brother mark's the other
brother so the guy's really good looking
i'm looking at the other guy and they're
very nice now any hotel that you go to
has these type of kitchens
the best thing they have on the menu is
like a soup that came out of a can
and they got a roast beef
with horseradish on it if i did it
i got stuck in because one time i stayed
this hotel that was it in that area they
came and picked you up in a half hour
early that's how far it was from
civilization
so all you can eat is that food it's
[ __ ]
you can eat it one day on the second day
you're not gonna feel good about
yourself
but the eggs aren't bad when i checked
into the whole time i go [ __ ] it to one
of these
so the next one i got up you know me i
get up at the hotel in the morning i
jump in the shower
i go downstairs i already got a joint
which i hide in the wallet
i got a lighter i got my [ __ ] phone i
got my glasses
i got my ass um i got my hotel key in
the back pocket so i'll rub it up
against my cell phone then the magneto
stops
then you're gonna go back downstairs and
activate the magnet
but by that time the shit's rolling down
your [ __ ] because you were running to
the bathroom
another time when the magnet runs out is
when you have [ __ ] running out of the
[ __ ] and you were counting on this
magnet of life to open the [ __ ] door
all right now you have to go back and
now you're going to go back downstairs
without they give you a new key and
they're going to look at you plus you
got to wait online now because now a
boatload of orientals
checked in there's 16 of them and
they're going to go through their
passport nobody speaks english i was
going to ask
whether polo they gotta wait for the
[ __ ] translator you have no idea
please i've lived this life for years
the bus had just arrived yeah you don't
know what it's like to [ __ ] go back
downstairs
you got a [ __ ] and pissed like a savage
you look in the bathroom everybody
there's feet in there
oh damn there's one toilet you look in
there there's feet in there you don't
know how many times i've knocked on the
woman's bathroom oh and if there ain't a
[ __ ] yelling there hello is tommy in
there
nothing i'll zip in that woman's
bathroom now [ __ ] that bathroom up
and if it's got a lock to it you ain't
coming in i'll make believe like did you
not see this was a woman's bathroom
no i had no idea let me explain
something to you i had some cheese it
was terrible
i didn't give a [ __ ] if it was the
woman's bathroom i don't give a [ __ ]
there was nobody in there was one stall
i had to pee in a with a girl in the
bathroom of the ice house the other week
the bat the other bathrooms was worth
and she went to the stall and i was like
i can wait she said no you can go and
but she wouldn't stop talking so i
couldn't
i had to tell her like guys don't
usually do that
did it make you feel uncomfortable yeah
i don't usually talk
let me get some shout outs here
wes woods bob lalingus
lorne rosenker bobby atkins
cody barnett dylan ortiz
r.g madden
dj swann
and the [ __ ] helm 512. who's
better than you [ __ ] savages
to all the moms out there happy mother's
day
if you're listening watch that monkey
flowers are coming you know what i'm
saying
flowers are coming lisa
yes sir
are you taking paula's mother out for
mother's day you guys well i think i
think it wasn't today mexican mother's
day if i'm not mistaken it doesn't
[ __ ] matter well listen
they're right
all that traditional [ __ ] you can't play
that yeah
that's what i think that's true don't
play that [ __ ] i don't care what they do
you tell them listen jews play sunday
like everybody else all right everybody
else
everybody else and the hallmarks
celebrate mother's day this [ __ ]
sunday okay
you want to tell me you want to show up
with the mexican thanksgiving
don't make me call trump
i can't say that to them that's like a i
hate that i'll that'll start a baby
right yeah
i'm a white guy surrounded by like a
whole sea of mexicans
oh my god
oh my god but um
did you either start becky
i took a piece of one but you didn't she
did let's see the recipe she took a tiny
bit it's behind that bag
on the table right behind her she
she kind of a purple one into 10 pieces
joey
i don't know how she got a ten pieces
that's how much i had
and that's the the lightweight ones
that's not even the nah but it's still
rocky world you know you'll get a little
loose and [ __ ] oh i feel it i can see it
i can see
you got that smile that says what the
[ __ ] did i get myself into
i want to get up tomorrow and do jumping
jinx
you said 10 times
without stopping you kept saying i'm
hungry you don't think i heard you i
just gotta overpower you every time i'm
gonna take that disrupt you that's your
mind throwing that reefer talk at you
that's every time you brought up food i
said i'm hungry there's no food now in
l.a you know that we got nowhere to go
oh no it's a wednesday night i know
where to go i know one place to go
you're gonna tell me that cheesy place
up in north hollywood huh that salsa and
beer or something no you go up to salsa
and beer right now they'll stab you
that's sherman whale lancashire you go
up there on your own they'll rip that
little [ __ ] cats right off your pants
you understand me oh my god you'll make
it to salsa and beer with no foot
they will rip those pants off you becky
you'll be in guadalajara
by 6 a.m dancing for like a bar full of
[ __ ] americans you go up to salsa and
beer
you only go to the south with me in the
daylight
let me tell you what time you go to
south side
best service
three 11 20 in the morning 11 20 that's
early though
because if you're there at 10 to 12.
it's like right after breakfast
you got to get up and smoke reefer
eat breakfast do some jumping jacks do
some
and then go there at 11 20 exactly have
to be walking through the door
that's when the food is fresh
it's empty still because by 12 10. oh
yeah lunch it's bumping the bumper up
yeah and it's bad you can't park you
can't like we tried to go there a couple
times we just had to leave yeah no no no
no it's it's true you got to go to 11
20.
we try to go for dinner oh no that's a
nightmare you're not going to get in
everything you'll be driving around that
parking lot
and that's when they sit behind the
fence and they watch it
and they're like let's see how many
times if this [ __ ] morons and if he
goes in there attack the lane pull them
out of the driver's side stab the wife
oh my god kill the dog you know you
don't need to do that [ __ ] that's a bad
[ __ ] neighborhood up there but the
food is dynamic i was going to tell my
man that's visiting in town
uh
rob madden
to go over there one night this week to
check out that [ __ ]
salsa and beer but you gotta get that 11
20 in the morning well that's not in one
night then that's huh
you said he has to go check it out one
day that means you gotta get up at six
smoke some dope have scrambled eggs
maybe no potatoes a little [ __ ]
slice of toast and three pieces of bacon
and you gotta just go down there you
know with some hunger and about 11 20.
isn't it here on vacation who i don't
know yeah yeah
so if the mom sleeps online smoke a
joint workout they can go eat some
mexican food for an earlier time update
sherman williams in the morning on your
vacation
spot people if you like mexican food
when people visit from out of town i
think i'm right there
and their [ __ ] head blows up what are
we talking about how are we going to
sell you were going you said you know a
spot
for food
what spot i don't know you said you know
a spot nobody said what's why are you
talking about wait
wait we don't know yeah we were waiting
invaded
we didn't you didn't get to that 20
milligrams ethan lately i don't know i
couldn't eat the last two you couldn't
eat the last two stars no i thought i
was gonna get sick
i'm high as [ __ ] right now but did we
eat a lot
i thought you were dude
what are you talking about what training
i had six stars
i finished those two
how many did you use six stars and then
i had
the
gum the taffy and half the chocolate bar
that's a lot of stuff
okay i gotta watch like a [ __ ]
hawkins i'm not lying about it
where'd this thing come from
that came from cleveland that's called
the savage
that's pretty cool no it's the real deal
it's the real deal when you take a hit
off that thing
it takes you to a different [ __ ]
planet
you want a little hit no i'm good right
now okay you want a little hit
i'm going right now
what days do you tape the podcast
now it's kind of all over the place so
you just tape it when you gotta know
whatever whenever yeah we're gonna do it
like tomorrow night we're gonna do one
we're at at my place
last week we did one at ellie jiujitsu
club
the week before i don't remember then i
i well we didn't do it for a couple
weeks because i was my neck was so bad
so
we've done some at a black house we've
done a few out there with their fighters
yeah
it's amazing the power of the [ __ ]
podcast
and the reset people have on them
trying
we're trying
i just looked i just looked at health
the other day
and i was blown away at the health
podcast
blown away on how many [ __ ] things
you could listen to and different blown
away
blown the [ __ ] way i hadn't looked at
that in like two years
it's it's somebody by now doubled in in
the past few years like probably more
than way more than that there's
thousands of podcasts yeah
thousands of podcasts thousands of
listeners because you can do it from
wherever that's why there was no [ __ ]
tv strike
they knew those [ __ ] knew they
strike it was over
between reality and the internet they
would be done for a long [ __ ] time
they'd never recoup
because somebody would figure out how to
do a thousand things on the internet
without all the [ __ ] hoopla there's
somebody out there who knows how to do
it right and they're just waiting to
pull this goddamn [ __ ] trigger you
know what i'm saying
i don't know if you saw i posted a uh uh
article that can isn't gonna allow
netflix
into its festival starting next year or
any anyone if they're not gonna put the
movies into the theaters
so like just so and so it's like it's a
punishment so like i bet i bet the movie
theater changed like a straight to
netflix type of thing yeah they don't
they don't want netflix to win that
because they'll probably have better
content
and then then it won't and won't go to
the movie theater so my question was
like have you ever been a part of
something that was going
to like try to get a reward or anything
did it like matter to you or
has that stuff have you never been a
part of something like that
lee from my world
i was lucky to get in the [ __ ] movie
you have to leave the academy award is
something completely different
to be in a movie that wins an academy
award
you gotta know [ __ ] that know
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
i could be i remember a commercial movie
an academy award movie is two different
[ __ ] things
yeah somebody really ha or somebody
really slick
has to have a vision about a movie and
go we can make this an academy award
with
this is how it has to be shot
or somebody look at each other nope
becky
call that dumb kid tell them to put
another script together for
guardians of the galaxy eight
this time tell them they gotta fight
martians and they blow up [ __ ] little
kids
i don't give a [ __ ] what they write on
toilet paper
we're gonna make it for 82 million
dollars and we're gonna make 250 000
billion dollars worldwide
that's a difference there's a difference
creativity to that you know what i'm
saying
that's why you look at some films and go
oh
i know why they did that film and oh now
you know why i did that film right you
know you learn a lot from looking at
who made these films yeah who's making
this from warner brothers
shiny in production
makes this movie and they make this you
know it's pretty interesting when you
look at it
when you're an [ __ ] like me and you
have time to look at that stuff i mean
it's like i get on the computer
and look at the history of chine and
whatever
but it's pretty interesting what type of
movies they pick up or
they don't pick up you know so
that's the difference in creativity when
they shot spider-man 2 they knew
spider-man 2 wasn't going to be an
academy award winner even though it did
win
something for like music or
well yeah or side effects there's no
facts yeah special effects
but beside that the script wasn't going
to [ __ ] make you cry at the movie
theater unless you were half broken
[ __ ] and you sat for the tickets for
22 hours outside in the winter time and
froze your last i lost a finger
but i saw spiderman too he and himself
came out
oh my god so no
those are the differences you know like
uh
when you look at the godfather they knew
they [ __ ] knew you know they knew
when they wrote that script that no i
think they knew when they picked it up
if they marketed the movie with strong
actors
they could win something you know i know
when i when
when you look at something go
we could take this spin shoot it this
way
we the
understand this how we this is our
vision and the writer's vision
and we're going to shoot it this way
we're going to get a powerful actor here
this one's going to cost us we might
break even
but we go to the [ __ ] we go to abc
february 15th and we walk up there 15
[ __ ] times
you know what i'm saying
so always keep that in mind
when they're shooting a film they know
exactly why how
and when when they release these movies
they know exactly what they're gonna
make on this movie
if they bomb guess what it's a write-off
they're gonna make 352 billion dollars
on some cartoon work with alec baldwin
who's playing a boss or something like
that
maybe not here but a [ __ ] hong kong
and that makes up for that loss
so don't cry ever about movies when they
flop
because on the other side they're making
a movie about grapes jumping up and down
singing and kids are going crazy over it
plus they're buying great hats for 1995
when they're making them in bulgaria for
52 cents
you know saying every time they make a
hat a kid dies shot
for them to make 1950 profit on the hat
that's gonna [ __ ] dissolve in the
water slogan of the company exactly it's
amazing
but once you see it and once you
understand it
i've never read a script that they sent
me and said
this is going to be an academy award
winner
never have once
have i said to myself no
first of all you need a high power to be
an academy award winner
so i've never been in the movie with
[ __ ] the black dude girls man
and these days they go for all these
other [ __ ] you know
who the [ __ ] knows i don't know about
that
but that's it and that's that what's up
with you lisa i ain't looking good
becky with the cat pants on his [ __ ]
cha-cha
nobody can see him
no oh you don't need to say it means
that okay you keep that thing yourself
that little savage
there used to be a girl who
was living on my couch
and he he would mess with her and think
that he was going to have her
dance and it was in a bikini is in the
days when they were doing it out of my
spare bedroom with webcams
and she was going to dance with a bikini
no i didn't say it like that i was
something different than this [ __ ]
jamock i don't know she was living on
this
she still jokes about it she wants to do
it at your shows what
dan doesn't dance with the bikini no she
does that she would have she yeah she
was just late to the take a nanny kit
oh my god she would have done it
i know she'd be fit to vote but right
now we're looking for the portrait
shows i'm saying at that time so it was
three four years ago
things must have changed in [ __ ]
boston right
she's eating better
she gained some pounds who knows
bigger than mine right now no she would
never do that
she'd kill you but
i don't know i gotta go to [ __ ]
milwaukee i'm gonna have a great time i
haven't been there in like six goddamn
years
you're gonna see danny brown i'm gonna
see danny brown saturday night
in detroit
but i'm excited about milwaukee as much
as i am about [ __ ] detroit i'm gonna
decide to go to italy neighbor to
[ __ ] eat
i got matt fultron it's going to be
goddamn beautiful
very nice
how cool was it that the the you got to
switch rooms
i must have helped yeah yeah because by
tuesday you know
this is milwaukee you haven't been up
there in the last time i was up there i
was with rogan it was before ufc
whatever last big ufc was up in
milwaukee
that's the last time i was up there
maybe
six years ago seven years ago
yeah i think it might have been before
we got together i don't remember that
one yeah
yeah no it was way
and it was great and i used to go up
there
i went up there twice before the year
2000 to do comedy twice at the comedy
cafe
when the biker ran the room so i got to
know the area i got to know that
condominium it was filthy
but it wasn't bad for five days to get
you off the road
you had to worry about a hotel not until
monday and if you had you he let you
stay till tuesday i'm saying
milwaukee hill huh milwaukee milwaukee
[ __ ] yeah very nice got some cheeses
[ __ ] some crackers
and that's it when
some cheese and holes in it and some
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on you like swiss
cheese i love i love all types of
cheeses i can't eat this [ __ ]
that's so sad
what's that you can't eat cheese
i try to you know look at the size of it
i need cheese
i had cheese last night
that's all those pants are smoking
tonight
those pants on fire you had some cheese
last night like i was telling you
[ __ ] let me talk to you about
something all right
when i'm out there
banging it out like this weekend and i
know there's uh
none i don't know what's going on in
milwaukee but when i'm out there
i get left brother lee break it down
last time you broke down the lift how
long did you enjoy it
lyft is my favorite
uh ride service app it's it's the best
it's the they're more courteous the
rides are are cleaner they have this
great new uh display that says hi to
whoever it is so you know what because
sometimes if you're going out at night
you're going to places that a lot of
lifts are there it's nice to know which
one is yours it there's there it's the
best experience out there
well let me explain something to you
when you drive for lift the right ride
sharing app every trip can feel like a
walk in the park with lift you can pick
your own hours and work when you want
lyft can make driving
the best job in the world
only lift off as an app tipping when you
drive for lyft you keep a hundred
percent of the tips drivers have been
paid over 150 million tips since the
feature was introduced express pay
lets the drivers paid almost instantly
ins instead of waiting for weeks lyft
has even
taken the guesswork out of the pickups
the new amp device
uses color coding to help passengers
find their drivers
you can earn hundreds of dollars a week
plus tips you want to make more money
drive more it's never been easier to
give yourself a raise it's a simple
formula happy drivers means happy
passengers maybe that's why nine out of
10 lyft rides get a perfect
five-star rating so do me a favor
join the ride sharing company that
believes
in treating people
better all right go to lyft.com joey
you're sitting there you don't know what
to do you got that new car you got a
license go out there lyft.com joey today
and get a 500
new driver bonus
that's lift.com
joey 500
new car bonus
new driver bonus
limited time only terms apply all right
who's better than you you'll have
something to do you have a little job
and you'll make some money let me
explain something to you i'm happy
that i have these guys as my sponsor on
the show and i'll tell you why because
it's a great product especially if
you're young and you're out there
fighting for your life you ready
dollar shave club tremendous razors
quality razors
they last for
whatever existence the handle is
tremendous but here's the beauty
you got to get that doctor carver's
shave butter
that stuff
it's what's really crackalacking you
understand me you go in the shower
you put that uh condition in your head
do
while it's getting conditioned you comb
the head to over your ears and you slap
on
the doctor carve is shaved butter and
you work it into your whole beard in
your face
and about two minutes later builds a
bond in your face
you take that razor becky you shave that
[ __ ] you understand me
and as you see it you see that
the doctor cars shave brother stick to
the razor with your hairs
you don't have to shave an extra day
it's tremendous
you walk out of the shower you dry your
face they got to have to shave and bam
who's better than you dollar shave club
is the smarter choice
get a great shave at a great price
convenient delivered right to your door
it's an awesome
life hack and no brain of choice you no
longer have to schlep to the store to
buy a cheap disposable razor that gave
you a cheap shave cut yourself to debt
or spend a fortune on razors with
gimmicky shaving tech you don't need and
when you use
executive razer by dollar shave club
with their doctor carbon shea butter the
blade gently glades giving me a
tremendous shave you understand me that
dr carr shea butter is transfer it's
transparent for a more precise shave it
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights
razor bumps you can make a smarter
choice by joining dollar shave club you
understand me now for a limited time new
members get uh
the first month of executive razor with
a tube of dr carver's shave butter for
only five dollars with free shipping to
boot who's better
than dollar shave club after that the
raises are just a few bucks a month
that's a 15 value for only five dollars
in your first month you'll get awesome a
weightly handle a full cassette of four
cartridges and a tube
of shea butter after your first month
replacement cartridges ship
automatically at their regular price
there's no hidden fees
no commitments cancel any time do me a
favor you get this offer exclusively
because your family with dollar shave
club and this is it's a deal and a half
i've got a dollar shave club right now
preston church bam
that's
dot dollarshaveclub.com slash church
boom and get your first month at the
executive razor with the tube of dr
carmen shea butter for only five dollars
i want to thank dollar shave club i also
want to thank lyft.com
joey what's up lee i i love dollar shave
club i have the same i'll eat some
handle that i've had i've had since
started yeah i've had it i still haven't
felt the same razor i still got razors
it's unbelievable and the doctor [ __ ]
the doctor makes it even better
becky over at matt therapy i love you to
death i love you too tell them when the
new podcast is dropping what do you
think i'll drop i will have one out
either tonight or
by tomorrow morning but you have how
many episodes they have a big catalog
because i'm gonna go over through
they've had 50 that was 56. they've had
hannah laronde
yep they've had any bravo one yep you've
had [ __ ] movie stars on a bunch of
ufc fighters
with [ __ ]
it's been fun and we're having a beach
party on saturday
oh it doesn't rain is it gonna rain no i
think it might be a little cooler than i
expected but
but we're gonna have a beach party so
all right so i'll see you [ __ ]
if i'm not in the beach party
so i think you'll be in detroit there's
nothing i want to be more at the beach
party
that's even your little jiu-jitsu shirt
you know what i'm saying
sweating looking all beautiful and hot
like you always do
becky rodriguez is always throwing
[ __ ] heat you know what i'm saying
michael jackson
he was my favorite as a kid who's that
michael i know he was i know you're a
professional skater he used to do all
the moves and [ __ ]
maybe if you're lucky sally i'll show up
and put the skates on there you go you
could do michael jackson your bikini
down at the [ __ ] venice beach sounds
good
get out there feeding
all right i'll see you [ __ ] at
the pabst theater
friday night with matt fultron don't
forget we're gonna [ __ ] light that
place on fire all right the spirit of
jeffrey dahmer is making a comeback i
love you [ __ ] one more time
dollar shave club one more time
lyft.com one more time honest.com
i'll see you [ __ ] monday
[Music]
so
you